Sonic the Hedgehog is off to the races
after a troubled production history that
involved a complete redesign of the
title character due to the first trailer
giving fans nightmares
the first live-action vehicle for the
speedy blue hedgehog from the iconic
Sega video game series is here and the
general consensus not too shabby
sonic famously had its release date
pushed back from late last year due to
the redesign which became necessary
after fans took to social media in
droves to express their bewilderment
disappointment and abject terror at
Sonic's weird eyes rip thighs and
bizarrely human teeth fortunately for
the filmmakers the VFX shots featuring
Sonic in the trailer were the only ones
that had been finished so it wasn't a
complete overhaul studio paramount had
to shell out a fair amount of dough to
make it happen though so the fact that
critics are so far pleased with Sonic
has got to be a relief for the studio's
brass the movie is certified fresh' on
Rotten Tomatoes and the positive notices
generally agree that while Sonic is far
from perfect
it's a breezy good time which benefits
from a quick pace which is really only
fitting it's not even necessary to be a
fan of the video game series to enjoy
Sonic as noted by Johnny Ola kenski of
the New York Post who wrote the movie is
a lot better than it deserves to be
you'll actually care about what happens
to the prickly blue dude even if you
never cared about getting to zone 7
Sonic the Hedgehog is very much in
conversation with Pokemon detective
Pikachu a fair number of critics such as
the Washington Post's Kristen Page Kirby
seemed genuinely shocked to be turning
in a positive review the headline of her
review contained a double-take reading
quote Sonic the Hedgehog is sweet funny
and smart
wait what the author praised Sonic as
quippy without being mean and sweet
without being sappy making it a trip
that's well worth taking in general the
flicks positive reviews found it to be a
fun family-friendly action-packed ride
with a distinct 90s by the weekend
warriors Edward Douglas put it like this
is it possible that Sonic the Hedgehog
is the first thoroughly entertaining
movie of the year yes indeedy negative
reviews meanwhile found
the hedgehog to beat just mediocre those
who disagreed with the majority found
Sonic to be a half-hearted effort not to
mention derivative of better films such
as ET and devoid of a unique sense of
humor referring to Sonic's infamous
original design a a doubt of the a/v
Club wrote when Sonic opens his mouth
you maybe wish those ghastly teeth are
still there if only to distract from the
lazy wisecracks pop culture references
and earnest cliches that come flooding
out it's that kind of movie a nattering
chore of a family comedy that feels
written by committee and directed by an
indifferent machine some negative
notices at least conceded that kids as
always will probably be into Sonic even
if it may leave their parents eyeing the
exit sign USA TODAY's Brian Truitt wrote
the film is fine familiar fare for
gamers and children Sonic's prints Jim
Carrey mugs but the creative juices run
out quickly in some critics though the
flicks simply engendered outright
hostility Evan da sea of Midwest film
journal wrote it's been a long road for
Sonic the Hedgehog to the silver screen
considering it's a thirty-year-old
intellectual property that hasn't been
relevant for two decades a long crazy
talent sinking road that leads to
nowhere
Sonic the Hedgehog joins an endless
stream of attempted IP resurrections
destined to litter the bottom of the box
office forgotten until their inevitable
reboot or R equal regardless of whether
or not the movie was their cup of tea
critics agreed near unanimously on one
thing Jim Carrey turns in an
unrestrained manic performance the likes
of which we haven't seen for decades in
a positive review total films Jordan
Farley called Carrie's performance
preposterous adding that adults in the
audience would find it to be quote an
enjoyable shot of nostalgia Travis
Hopson a punch-drunk critics wrote
whatever message the movie might have is
secondary to Carrie who dominates
literally every moment he's on screen
giving such an exaggerated wacky
performance it makes fire marshal bill
look positively tame in other words
Sonic the Hedgehog looks like a heck of
a lot of fun perhaps surprisingly if
nothing else it deserves to be
remembered as a product at that time
when fans chimed in with their tea
since on social media about how a film
could be made better and the filmmakers
actually listen regardless of how you
may feel about Sonic that in itself is a
minor miracle check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite movies
and TV shows are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]